la sta colando bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono va vj oggi
siamo su un wizard che volevano fare un
nome più lungo quindi hanno ripetuto due
volte la stessa cosa con ragazzi siamo
su whizard whizard questo buffo è un
figo della madonna ma giuro è un
videogioco che mi avete consigliato in
parecchi da significa che vi deve
incazzare bellissime belliche sono i
gabbiani apix kong ragazzi sono un mago
che dovrei essere perfetto ma cazzo ci
arrivano a double jump caccia fatto una
scoreggia io posso saltare due volte per
merito delle scorre generò babel
io amo già questo gioco un nuovo
spaventosa andato a una parte non
avvicinarsi a quella roba sei tranquillo
che qui al mio amico pinocchio
principessa è stata trasformata in una
stato aiuto
vabbè ma che bella è stata principessa
rega ma io ho il potere delle scorregge
io posso farti chiavi si è sposato il
computer a caso nel bellissimo e ragazzi
a otto mesi che 6 ott
c'è qualcuno che ha fatto una
maledizione la principessa e credo che
sia stato un ragazzo vestito di rosso
porca mi ha scoperto mai niente
ragazzi andiamo avanti o guarda c'è una
chiave sono morto potrei della scorra
sono vivo è con de klan la classe e
classe né bellissimo stomaco e fare
meraviglioso cioè se a me ma poi ci sono
i gufi grazie dell'aiuto amico vi va
bene ragazzi e comunque in questa sera
tanto muoio sì mi sono ribellato a metà
poi vediamo un attimo è in cure il
signor nam
qual è il tuo numero colta zia
mettiamoci d'accordo va bene aprendo la
chiave che perfetto per puro e fattibile
non è dice ancora tu resti salvare la
principessa ami come va bene dove cazzo
è la principessa se mi dici dove ma è
una mucca questa è una mucca può pensare
di salvare la principessa lei è mia io
ti sto guardando
io veramente non va a fan culo può mai
sbagliare un chi no ma no lurida testa è
l'amore per me la mucca che porta sfiga
io non so sto dubbio ci ha messo
mezz'ora a prendere una chiave discount
sei sono molto solo sei volte sono perso
mi dispiace azienda sta diventando
stanza più difficile di prima è però io
sono un fenomeno io sono tutto io lo
faccio guardalo beh quasi io io sono un
fenomeno io posso non riesco a stata no
no non risposta sì si no bellissimo
quando scoraggia perché fa piano piano
si si
ho vinto bene io io sono un gufo non me
ne frega un cazzo tipo le chiama quelle
che sono le chiavi volanti con le di
harry potter ragazzi è difficilissimo
sta diventando impossibile ma guarda che
roba come faccia prendere ma se non
salto che se non c'è per non è possibile
si no come ho fatto a mancarla per
niente in uscita sì sì sì ma dio mio
ma dio cosa ho fatto rega abbassa troppo
wire you looking at punk non lo so zio
per farmi andare avanti e mi sto
incazzando abbastanza bravo e la madonna
è la madonna you suck che grazie io non
avete i gufi che mamma che schifo di
gioco di merda che ho fatto e tra tutti
i giochi di niente ma perché salve sono
un deficiente accaduta ma perché ma
perché è dotato se non vado lì adesso
devo pensare col mio cervello che già è
difficile usarlo donna a donna è madonna
un cazzo si va da dove cadono e va come
faccio a raggiungere la chiave
impossibile
eh sì la cosa triste è che non so quanto
dura sto gioco quindi potrebbe essere
tragico non presto
ma chi è ma chi è perché se ragazzi si è
pagato il gufo è una roba fenomeno ma
don tanta roba troppa roba
ok madonna cos'ha fatto
madonna è la scusa che quando c'è la
propaggine ragazzi io pensavo che al 10
niente pensavo che a dieci ci fosse la
principessa ma non c'è un cazzo quindi
mi devo arrangiare andando alla con
bello sto gioco a parte coseco la roba
c'è un tizio che sputa delle cose con la
barba non voglio sapere perché ma va
bene lo stesso dovevo andare il quadro
devo passare in mezzo astico e va beh ma
mica ci voleva pure mai nessun uomo nel
mondo invece sì che culo
non so neanche come bene brano troppo
forte per feliciano e la forza di
gabbiani zio chi cazzo sei tu ragazzi
justin bieber la la la la cena i suoi
tunes questa mi piaceva come cosa è
carino bello ok ok 50 morti mi stai
prendendo per il culo spiega mano ok
sì sì sì
[Musica]
no cosa cosa ho fatto che botta di culo
ragazzi mi sono salvato non so neanch'io
come ma va bene così come diavolo dovrei
fare devo correre in casa nando rega
se si è fatta
sicché botta di culo incredibile va
perfetto ormai ho fatto sta roba credo
di non riuscire a fare più niente ma va
bene ok ok no ma non c'è la mira mio dio
cioè alla vista di un vecchio per fare
sta roba
non lo so non vi dico la roba decente
non ho visto la principessa come faccia
prendere la chiave ha così ambo se è più
semplice di quanto pensa cosa vuoi tu
zio ho dimenticato la mia password di
facebook co me non è un problema mio zio
però va bene mi dispiace avete pazienza
però non è che posso aiutarlo io
preferirei perdere la password di
facebook che giocherà sta roba mica è
roba inutile
cosa ho appena fa basta cioè io dove
obama con le medaglie non passare in
mezzo poi madonna deve essere un
fenomeno tipo ok troppa roba
ragazza iniziando p.zza madonna cosa
cosa stavo per fare che mi potevo
incazzare alquanto non si può
e assurdo sì no no no no li mortacci tua
sì sì che porta ad altre caduto pure la
bottiglia come cazzo tutta la bottiglia
[Musica]
vabbè ragazzi faccio la bottiglia così
perché siamo arrivati alla parte dove
c'è cappuccetto rosso e voglio vedere se
gli scorci cos'è un arma una giusto non
mago che usa le armi press spacebar
mamma nicchia che proiettile è morto è
morto è morto la boe e bastato un colpo
ho vinto davvero
ma pensavo fosse un livello impossibile
tipo che ci fosse un boss della madonna
invece no beh quello che è successo e
che la prima principessa non era di
pietra dopotutto è la statua che
sembrava la principessa era soltanto il
progetto di arte di qualcuno o infatti
l'hanno trovata anni dopo mentre stava
dormendo
quindi io che cazzo giocato a fare ma
lei adesso ai un'arma che spacca il culo
gli end vabbè ragazzo è stato c 151
morti pensavo peggio vero vi sia
piaciuto soprattutto finale nuovamente
il boss finale è stato è stata la
battaglia più etica della storia dei
videogiochi credo che la posso rivedere
un attimo anch'io qualche è stato
bellissimo morto la mia faccia
ma io sono veramente così nei video va
bene comunque ragazzi lascio perdere
perché è stato bello ma bello proprio
giuro non incluso fine pisati ragazzi
selvi dove è piaciuto e se pensate che
il finale sia degno di oscar lasciate un
commento mi piace anche a pagani
facebook e come non inoltrata
descrizione se non se ne avresti scritto
prossimo ragazzi